y según este informe la situación de
seguridad también la situación de los
derechos humanos en colombia estatal
parece que peor que antes que fue lo que
no hizo el gobierno eduque a lo largo de
estos últimos cuatro años de gobierno
pues lo que no hizo el gobierno para
implementar los
compromisos que en materia de seguridad
y otros compromisos traía el acuerdo de
paz el gobierno decidió reemplazar los
contenidos del acuerdo de paz por un
programa denominado pasto en legalidad
que es básicamente la proyección de su
propia estrategia de seguridad y defensa
y que consiste básicamente en la
militarización de los territorios y no
concentrarse en la seguridad de los
líderes sociales de las organizaciones y
las zonas más afectadas por el conflicto
y esto llevó a una expansión de grupos
ilegales especialmente grupos
paramilitares que iniciaron una racha de
atentados contra los liderazgos
que ha venido creciendo en estos cuatro
años no solamente atentados contra
líderes sociales sino masacres
desplazamiento confinamiento
reclutamiento forzado
y los indicadores que dan que han
llevado a una verdadera crisis
humanitaria en una situación dramática y
el país el gobierno del presidente iván
duque señoría le preguntó por el acuerdo
de paz que es tal vez uno de los temas
de más importancia y relevancia a nivel
internacional en este informe dicen que
el gobierno de duke digamos saboteo la
implementación del acuerdo es muy lento
y muy poco los avances que hay porque lo
hizo esto hace referencia a una
estrategia política
y yo creo que la razón estriba en que el
acuerdo contemplaba al compromiso de
realizar reformas
sociales económicas para los cuales el
gobierno de iván duque no estaba
dispuesto a implementar el gobierne
bando que implementó un modelo pro rico
pérez y mantiene un modelo anti pobre
que concentró profundamente la riqueza
que empobreció
sectores importantes de la población que
tuvo indiferencia frente a los reclamos
sociales de la población en el contexto
de la pandemia y efectivamente todo esto
se hizo con ejercicio de una gran dosis
de violencia como siguió en el estallido
social del año 2020 que la protesta a
sus 7
a ver reprimir
7 pesos asesinas y mil 900 personas
heridas todo esto iba en contra de los
acuerdos de paz que buscaban sacar la
violencia a la política y ofrecían
garantías a los movimientos sociales
para poder ejercer sus reclamos por las
vías legales y sin necesidad de apelar a
la violencia señores pues con este
panorama que usted describe y también
con lo que dice este informe que reto
entonces tiene el presidente que va a
asumir el liderazgo en este país que va
a llegar a la casa de nariño en menos de
dos meses por dónde comenzar por la
implementación del acuerdo por
garantizar seguridad por garantizar
derechos humanos por dónde comenzar cuál
es el reto
pues creo que el reto comienza por
reconocer la dramática crisis
humanitaria en que deja el país el
gobierno dejando que formular un plan de
acción o un plan unitario los primeros
100 días que permitan llegar a acuerdos
humanitarios con todos los actores que
ejercen control y terror sobre las
comunidades y los territorios de tal
manera que se pueda sacar la población
civil del conflicto que se pueda sacar
la violencia que están sometidos
distintas organizaciones en territorios
y de esa manera conducir rápidamente el
país hacia un acuerdo de paz con todas
las insurgencias volver a la vía del el
cumplimiento de los acuerdos de paz con
las farc que fueron paralizados lo mejor
fueron revertidos con el inicio del
gobierno eduque y efectivamente también
adelantar políticas sociales políticas
de derechos humanos y sobre todo el
restablecimiento del estado de derecho
la profundamente resquebrajado por el
gobierno de abanto